[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits unlink and I'm
Rhett joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting is YouTube's
reigning king of music video parodies
Bart Baker Bart is killing it with his
parodies he's become the guy that
everybody looks to to parody the latest
popular song and in the process he's
racked up over five million subscribers
in over a billion billion billion feet
what is a billion I said billion three
times but just over a billion that's not
a billion when you say it three times in
a row there's a lot I mean we don't have
to try to I was trying to do it borracho
but you know a billion billion nobody's
got that many views that would be crazy
now Bart shape-shifts from Robin Thicke
and Adam Levine to Katy Perry and Lord
with an arsenal of high production
values and many times a shot-for-shot
approach to parody no pop star is safe
from as critical even sometimes
controversial roasting lyrics if you've
never heard of seen Bart's videos here's
a clip for his Miley Cyrus wrecking ball
parody where he of course is Miley
[Music]
since the VMAs all the people say I am a
total scary grinded Robin Thicke made
the whole crowd sick especially the
Smiths
that one's got over 65 million views and
here's his more recent blank space
parody with over 25 million views where
he plays a demon-possessed Taylor Swift
[Music]
[Music]
in this biscuit we talk with Bart about
what he really thinks about the
musicians he parodies and what pitbull
thought of Bart's parody of him pitbull
pitbull I think you mean pitbull no I
know he's to me cuz I know him he's
pitbull pitbull plus we discuss how he's
perceived publicly in his private
insecurities is there more to Bart Baker
than what you think you know about him
from his videos hmm you be the judge but
first we want to remind you that you can
support the show by checking out
lynda.com/rhettandlink ly nba.com Rhett
a nd link you spell that out for us
thank you appreciate that you're welcome
whether you want to take better photos
or shoot better video with your DSLR
learn the programming skills to develop
your own mobile app or edit your own
video footage using Final Cut Pro
premiere lynda.com offers thousands of
video courses to help you get what you
want to be you can learn at your own
pace on your own terms and you can get a
free 10-day trial by going to lynda.com
slash rhettandlink and I will say that I
recently sat down to attempt to edit a
holiday video a little video that we
made during our trip over Christmas
you've been putting that off put it off
and as I sat down to edit I realized
that link I've lost it which is why
you've been putting it off which is a
great problem to have we've got people
who do the editing for us now we don't
do and I mean you did it for a long time
even after I stopped but it's been so
long that I it's not like riding a bike
I can't do it anymore
the software has changed too much so if
I'm going to successfully edit my
holiday video I instead of asking you or
asking Ben for help I'm gonna go to ask
Linda because she's got it figured out
I'm gonna go to later calm can I take
advantage of our own of the free truck
and I do that myself
no Dodd can tell I can't tell him that
I'm that I'm rhett and Link I just that
I'm Rhett from Ren link you could yes
but I feel weird about that if you're
gonna use my account it's well I'll make
a decision for myself but in the
meantime you guys can go to lynda.com
slash rhett and Link and try it free for
10 days on us now here's our Bart Baker
biscuit
when I saw you last you were there your
dad yeah your dad was in town from where
sort of Chicago okay and you met parts
dad yeah yeah I explained you guys with
him yeah yeah
Did you touch him I shook his hand I
touched his hand didn't touch my hand
why would you ever hurt you did he touch
your dad is that have you had problems
no I mean it's just I think that's
that's a good name for a song honestly
why did you touch my dad did he touch
your dad it seemed like a like a
straight-up dude
yeah he's a YouTube freak he knows
everyone oh really that's like yeah he
follows every he's on socialblade 24/7
checking numbers on everyone is it
really yes is it like a I'm your dad but
I feel like I could be your manager
agent so it's more like competition
there is he a fanboy
he's a fanboy of who everyone on on
YouTube really yeah yeah it's not just
you he's not just out of his son
no he's just she's super stoked that I'm
you know doing YouTube but like he's
he's just like a fan of everybody so did
you get him into what's his name yeah
buddy buddy buddy baker buddy baker
buddy baker Barbic buddy baker is almost
maybe better than Bart Baker that's not
too good names I mean he could start a
channel did you get buddy into youtube
or are you - no no no I got him into it
um you know he was a little bit it took
him a while to get into it but he really
just all of a sudden just like one day
the switch flipped and he knows everyone
on YouTube now I think he did ask
something about link really have a me
but would that have massive sum well I
want to think that buddy did I like I
want the thing to think that buddy did I
I don't take this the wrong way where
they're linked you know it's it's good
when you start a sentence with don't
take this the wrong way yeah I'm just
gonna be honest kind of stream of
consciousness here when I hear the name
buddy I think about
I blind uncle Melvin's dog oh-hoo and
that was his name huh he called him
buddy and he was a beagle but he wasn't
as he looks he wasn't a seeing-eye
beagle because uncle Melvin didn't need
that
my Papa Clyde it was his brother and he
lived across the street and in his old
age he he lost his eyesight so we'd go
over and visit with him and this is like
I was very young I'm like talking him
yeah five or six years old because he
passed away when I was probably like
seven so I remember going over to see
uncle Melvin and then we would we'd walk
him outside to see buddy in the pen
it was buddy in the YouTube videos this
is that where this is going
no his name was buddy that's where this
that's where it's going so yeah well you
know if you tell me more about your dad
Brian if it can replace but he can be my
buddy yeah like whenever I hear the word
buddy I can thank Barbara you should
call him on Instagram he's trying to
blow up he is yeah I mean he gets more
likes than most of my like people I know
what does he Instagram he's just like
take selfies like driving in his car or
like when he's on trips or he'll post
like a throwback Thursday what it's like
the family thing is I picture him like
dressed just like you like seeing a
black t-top
I wish like he's a banker he's uh yeah
he's pretty straight-laced looking guy
yeah totally we actually a lot of people
don't know he's my dad at first we
because he's he's like your lawyer or
something maybe yeah I mean you could
second see him being my lawyer yeah yeah
but we're totally different career paths
you know what I mean he was a Yale grad
perfect SAT scores didn't miss a single
question like Wow and then he went to he
went to whatever it's called what do you
do after graduation graduate school yeah
he went to Northwestern so he knew
Chicago from there but he did it like
he's a totally different so but he's the
ultimate fanboy cuz it's like he'd never
got to do this stuff and now he gets to
come to LA and like experience it
through me how often does he come out
he's probably actually like for business
he's here probably like three times a
year but the
with my mom maybe another like - let's
give let's give her my mom Jan Baker is
also a big fan she's a she's not like my
dad are they still together oh yeah
they're together where do they live they
live in Chicago suburbs of Chicago and
yeah you know my dad's like like a nerdy
fan girl I'm just gonna call him a
fangirl cuz that's that term right yeah
and then my mom is just more she doesn't
watch other YouTube people she just
watches my stuff when I tell her to cuz
she doesn't even really get how to work
her computer so the fan mom Dan he's a
fan mom yeah get it and she likes to
brag about what I do she tries to not
burr like start the conversation like my
son dresses his Taylor Swift in
Hollywood for a living but it ends up
that way is there is there an element of
oh one of my parents gonna think of this
one because yeah not anymore
grandparents maybe okay I don't know if
they watch them or not but they're very
very rare you're not like when when you
visit them you're not like pulling them
up oh hey guys anyway I don't react to
this so long to see it no but what do
you tell them you're doing they know
what I'm doing and they've seen a couple
and I think they don't watch them
they're like you should do videos that
are more catered towards elderly Channel
yeah like just for their elderly people
they can't like do parodies about like
like nursing homes I was like why you
see use old people in my videos so that
is a growing demographic though yeah I
know I mean we're gonna be in it one day
right true so yeah you know that's the
only thing I and I don't think about it
really because I can't let that make me
hold back just be like oh my
grandparents don't think this is gross
so they're super you said they're super
religious like super conservative yeah
is that is there like a trickle-down
scenario from parents to you what was it
what was your upbringing like and where
was that upbringing was in Chicago for
most of it I lived in North Carolina for
a year which is interesting and then
back what part of my car
winston-salem okay we're from North
Carolina so wow really we know about the
Joe Salem you just breathe the air and
it's like smoking cigarettes around
Winston so oh yeah
depending on the year oh yeah yeah mrs.
Salem was interesting it was all brand
new developments and how you know all
the houses were just like just put up so
we were in the middle like a farmland
basically uh-huh and it was just like a
brand new area so it was totally
different than what I was used to you
know but then you went right back to
right back to Chicago yeah so I've been
in Chicago most of my growing up that's
where I was really for it for all of it
what was the situation at home in terms
of you know were you guys there were
certain things you couldn't watch on
television like object how strict with
your parents so I was really bad in
school like not meant not like you know
my grades are good but I was
troublemaker so they were example um
example god I mean I I got I made
pancakes once and I put the the strain
strainer hair in the pancake batter and
I mixed it up and I gave the pancakes to
my social studies teacher
I watched her eat them it was your hair
roundup no it was hair for the drain
from other people it was just in the
drain Oh hair from the sink drew yeah
yeah stuff like that but then what does
she do when you initiate that she didn't
notice what we did she got him down she
ate him she was a bigger woman we
meaning all your classmates knew you
told them hey all new wood they helped
like that they were all in home a
Candler like we're gonna we were really
our class was so bad it was we had two
teachers quit during our eighth grade
year it was crazy so we changed that
school for did you get caught for the
pancake no we didn't get called for that
I did get caught for putting up lesbian
porn on the computer and then changing
every single volume when you push the
volume on those old Macs and make a beep
I figured out how to change it to say
smoke and all of every single computer
lab computer would say schmuck and I got
banned from all the computers for like
six months but it was worth it stuff
like that I was trying to be crooked I
could switch it back so for the next six
months you
Laidback is its mom the guy what's it
called what's it what's the name of the
person who's in charge of computers at
schools the IT guy maybe that's it
he's a lot of stuff though so he was
also a teacher his face looked like
hamburger meat so we called him
hamburger face but he got real red when
he heard those noises so it was like he
was really like a raw piece of meat I
think he still works there did you have
any brothers and sisters I was the only
child just dogs so that you know but
honestly like well hamburger face is a
good example here because what you're
telling me is you know you've got almost
a supernatural ability to push the
buttons of the artist that you're
parodied right we'll get through this a
little later but I imagine them watching
your work and you know I just get this
sense that there's a you know you know
where to you know where to hit him yeah
research but it sounds like that was
that was just something that came
naturally
naturally gave you all that guy's face
it looks like I am Burger where you
should call him maybe it's ain't good I
was good with nicknames sure just
figuring out things that I could relate
and it'll drive him nuts it'll make his
hamburger aw yeah if I put schmuck on
all the yeah computer works man he was
pissed and were you a did you see early
on that okay when I do this kind of
thing when I come up with this nickname
when I put the hare and the pancakes
everybody reacts in a positive way to it
well obviously all the key what all the
classmates loved it because we were
everyone in the class was bad so
everyone kind of fed off of each other
and yeah so it was directed towards I
mean were you the bully
was it directed toward classmates now
there was an now it was just teachers
the teachers were mean they were really
mean some of them some of them we were
cool with and we're the teachers were
really cool but some teachers were just
like you know I some teachers just don't
know how to keep kids under control they
do it by trying to be just like we
didn't
I guess what should they have done for
Bart Baker I think it would have stuff
just the way that if someone does one
thing wrong don't send him to the
principal's office right away
maybe actually explain to him why that
was bad and then try to be a little cool
or try to relate to them on a different
level so you feel like maybe you're
friends with them you know instead of
just saying you mm-hmm
so you're still bitter about it I've
some of these teachers some of them I'm
trying to think of a teacher I really
didn't like I had some features I was
like really cool with and then
everything in high school was all just
like normal yeah it was just in junior
high well you think I'm making the
videos too
yeah yeah that started early like fifth
grade oh yeah
yeah what's an early one you remember
the first video I remember doing was
this video where we took our hands and
put shoes on them so it would look like
we're skateboarding and doing these rad
tricks would be like this dude skating
and it would be like him about to jump
and it would cut like the feet going and
like grinding and then like it looked
really fake but it was really funny so
it was like this skateboard movie and it
was it was funny as hell that was the
first one added in edited it in camera
those are the best those little what are
those crappy old v8 Mini Mini TV it
wasn't those it was VHS see yeah that
was it was ability in a bigger view yeah
you had to put the little yes that's
what we got started on right yeah that's
it yeah yeah so that was a fifth grade
and then and then in in high school of
really started pumping out like I did my
first music video in high school and we
I went around selling DVDs of that thing
I think I sold like 300 copies and was
that a funny a funny video it was it was
actually so it was a music video that we
we had an assignment that we we could do
like anything we wanted for this class
and we want to do a music video
and we took a song it was already made
it was get your roll on by the
big-timers well did you put this on
youtube it's on YouTube yeah it's your
first video yes I put that up like but I
put it up probably like four years after
he made it he okay so you made that a
nice guy was the first music video I
ever did and you it was a lip sync video
that was a lip sync video yeah but you
had some nice cars oh yeah where did you
get those from most of those cars were
parents cars we just took them okay
one of them was the ones that were
driving were parents cars the other ones
we went to the dealerships and we just
stole shots of so it look like we had
them and that was in the it seems like
the angle of that video was just hey
let's let's let's make a rap video for a
song that we like yeah let's just see
how if we can make it look like how
legit we can make it look you know cuz
everyone was we were like everyone was
super obsessed with Cash Money Records
back then so you got a grade but they
also got paid but yes you burn DVDs
insult 300 yeah we sold 300 and I got
written permission from Cash Money
Records to distribute you're kidding me
okay this is before they were huge right
so we found their number and I called
him I called him a secretary answer it's
like little Wayne isn't a phone or
something it was a secretary I was like
can I talk to the guy who owns the
company was Ames limb I got like I
talked to slim she's like all the boys
are out of town right now kind of leave
a message for him I'm like we're trying
to distribute this video and the
internet doesn't allow for that yet so
right I mean it wasn't even I don't even
think YouTube existed then they're
thinking this was 2002 uh-huh so there
is just like I don't remember why or we
got permission or it's not like you got
permission from the secretary secretary
yeah no but we got a contract they sent
it but really we had a signature and
everything saying we kids distributed
did they want to cut no they didn't care
but the fact that they lives they had
cash money they didn't care that was
back you know this is why did you bring
that in to I mean when now that it's on
your channel on YouTube does that is it
actually effective for that well I don't
it probably is can you take the Adsense
from that I don't know I don't even know
if I'm running ads on that I probably am
but that's hilarious
you know okay so that so you made that
in high school as high school yeah
sandy and then at some point you're
starting to think you wanna that you
want to be a filmmaker right that's what
I wanted to do originally was a
filmmaker director editor you know
behind the camera mmm and I went to
school for that and all that crap so
yeah so you where do you go to college
you went to college yeah major in film I
went to my you don't see Miami Florida
so how did how did you end up in Miami
out of that um so I just their film
school was really good it was like one
of the top five at the time so it was
like USC Miami UCLA and then it was all
of them I think it was mostly all
California than Miami
um and I actually knew one of my best
friend's stepdads was like where the
biggest like alumni there he's like
super into Miami so he was like you
should just go do like early interview
show him one of your videos so I showed
him the the get your role on video
uh-huh and they're like okay you're in
yeah they're like you're in they told me
that when I was there like you're in
early admission sounds pretty awesome
yeah so I just went there so I don't
want to worry about writing I say what
was the Miami Film School la experience
Miami's a weird school it's different
than normal like it's in my own life
there's a there's a Miami there's a
constant tension that you could be
underwater at any moment right that's
yeah so everyone's really angry had hurt
no one likes to party yeah we had one
likes to have fun no no I know we had
like the first week I was there we had a
hurricane hit and basically when
hurricanes hit the dorms are locked up
and everyone just has sex and drinks
that's all you do cuz it's a dorm party
you're locked in your dorms you can't
leave
so there's the first week of school that
was crazy then it happened again and it
ripped up the whole campus and like the
late I remember looking out the window
and the whole lake was in the air
because it was like right over it was
crazy
besides that Miami's uh it was pretty
it's just
different dude it was like I was in a
fraternity - we just sucked the worst
experience ever so they didn't have so
you didn't have houses so yet like the
Greek life there sucked
basically it was like it ended up being
like okay well now I'm paying dues to go
to a meeting every week that I sit there
listening to this little guy talk about
how we're gonna like better our minds
and bodies and have parties and stuff
did you give him a nickname that guy oh
god I um did we give him a nickname I
feel like we did let me think
it's gonna come back to me I'm pretty
sure he did you know I just saw his
brother the other day they really he had
an identical twin I thought it was him
here in LA yeah I think he's like an
agent or something here does he was
sitting at Starbucks like yeah yeah and
he's really short so he's an agent or
something was the I mean the things I
hear from YouTube creators who had
brushes with film school yeah is that I
didn't do much for me yeah I agree
oh I didn't know it did it not not for
what I did because they taught me
old-school methods and I mean we shot
stuff on 16 millimeter and and they
didn't even we didn't use digital really
mmm
so yeah we edited on an avid like huge
like one of those big-ass Avid's you
know like I would never edit in one of
those again but you were there for four
years I mean four years yeah you got the
degree I got it
and is a degree in that and art and a
minor in psychology and it looks like a
number of videos that you probably made
during that time or on your channel -
they probably would like look into my
eyes well that was the bear that was
after you graduated that was right after
I got out of college and that was your
that was your first like break that was
the first viral video the one first one
to hit a hundred hundred thousand which
was crazy to me back then and that's a
totally different
rent approach them what you've kind of
adopted together so that was original
music how did you come up with the idea
of doing the song of that song yeah that
song was so lonely island inspired
that's like right when little island
blew up uh and I was just like this is
so cool that they can make music that's
funny and get so many views so what was
your mind so you were looking at them
but you just graduated yeah and what did
you know about your strategy I mean did
you say I'm gonna try this YouTube thing
or I'm just gonna yeah I'm gonna go to
LA and like get on a set I worked my way
back to Chicago okay right after college
didn't have any desire to go to LA what
was your plan I didn't have a plan I was
just like I'm taking a year off I'm not
gonna do anything and I didn't do
anything for a year except what you had
to do something I made that video and
then I drank a lot and you know partied
way too much lived lived at home yeah it
looked at home I think most of my
friends all lived at home right after
college they all came back to Chicago
and where your did buddy and Jan say
buddy and Jan what are what are you
gonna do bar like you should need to get
an internship since the idea I did some
internships so I think I might have had
an internship during this maybe it was
right after I don't even remember I
interned it I was doing editing for
Jerry Springer sure oh my goodness yeah
really well that's so it was really
random I found this internship and it's
a post house in Chicago that's where
they filmed Jerry Springer and Steve
Wilkos show yeah
that not anymore now they film it some
more weird that's cheaper so you get to
see uncut I would see the uncut dude and
I was really supposed to be like a
little like [ __ ] intern who work the
front desk but I was like I can edit and
they're like yeah whatever so they're
all actors right yeah no they're not
they're not that's the crazy part
they're all freaking weird real people
but I thought that they brought people
on Jerry Springer who kind of wanted
their 15 seconds of fame so to speak
that's probably true not even minutes
and then they play it up yeah then they
wait up
and they would probably give them
assignments in the way that you would
give someone on a reality if you were
producing a reality totally oh you're
listen you're playing yourself
but yeah you don't know who the real
father is right and when you find out
you probably want to get really upset
yeah matter of fact you probably want to
throw a chair huh
don't you think maybe yeah okay action
yeah that didn't happen well I couldn't
see what was happening behind the scenes
because we just got the footage but it
wasn't like they didn't there was no raw
footage of like an a director coming out
and now not really really it was pretty
live like they don't even stop it's
really like well that restores my faith
in ya you made any integer especially
film it all almost and they don't like
be late they don't they're not like cut
we need to do that again there's no
stopping down just do it so as I ended
up so you you left it not feeling what I
thought and what I just told you it's
like your eyes like no this is for real
these people have real is for real I
mean it seemed for real that people are
this there's how many people that are
that messed up they're all like not
there you know I don't really get what's
even happening there in a whole other
world but I enjoy editing it I ended up
editing the intros remember like those
you know those like those like before
the people would come out and they're
backstage yeah so it's like the intro of
the actual show where it's like this
episode on Jewish Springer it's like all
these stupid cheesy effects of like you
know like like I've been yet on like a
woman crying and then my crappy
transition so like a guy like in black
and white like he raped her and stuff
like that but it is an art form it
defined a genre of art if you ask me no
totally you know I got a I got a knack
for that somehow and they let me start
doing those they had editors that were
working there for like six years who
would do it but then they'd let me do it
then they asked me to move to frigging a
New York and they're like we want you to
be a full-time editor we're gonna give
you like 80 grand a year and I was like
no I want to do YouTube because by that
point look at see my eyes that's that
that video did well and then I put out
my first parody while I was there too
which did well which one was the first
one boom boom pow parody boom boom pow
okay called big old pubes
which is black eye peas black eye peas
yeah okay um yeah two point six eight
million views five years ago Wow and so
it's probably gotten residual views over
the yeah you know but it probably went
pretty big at the time it did okay I
think it was the same type of thing like
it did like a hundred thousand and like
a week or two and who was helping you at
the time like who was the guy in the
look into my eyes video that's just my
that was my friend rob who still lives
in his parents basement actually really
well you know there's a lot of room in
there nah it's a nice basement it's like
the whole but yeah footprint of the
house is yours
that's true that was just my friend I'm
like dude you got to put on the
spacesuit bro and listen and talk about
masturbating yeah and he was like I'm
down and then you did the Kesha tik-tok
parody yeah and then you did the
California Girls Katy Perry parody with
like this these two elderly dudes that
one was the first old person parody we
did I also should note that by this time
I'd been hired by a porn company alright
let's talk about you should we should
know that you moved from Springer it's
like where can I go from here I was at
Springer I got contacted by the owners
of reality Kings the biggest porn
company in the world the owners you know
they're like 32 they contacted you
because of your YouTube video yeah they
found that the word masturbate in it
they found the boom boom pow one okay
and they're like this is really funny
and I was like thanks and they're like
would you consider making like some
parodies for us and put like the the
watermark in the corner with a link and
I was like yeah sure and then somehow I
convinced him to hire me full-time move
me to Miami and because he wanted to go
back to my I didn't but they were
located on South Beach it was just like
kind of convenient because I already
knew the area so they actually that's
this wonderful water more water
Montevideo yeah those are our K water
marks so if I go to our K dot-com or
whatever that is that's a porn so it's
porn so hardcore porn the first thing
you'll probably see is a huge Exmouth
right when you get there okay but in in
so how do you come up with the idea
of okay the strategy for this is going
to be I'm gonna do a Katy Perry parody
right but it's gonna be two old dudes
that was I just got this idea originally
like why don't we do old people like
sing the hits like it would be funny
because they don't know the music or the
tempo or anything and then I was just
like well why don't we just put the damn
people in the parody and have them play
the characters and so we tried it and it
turned out people thought it was
hilarious and it got picked up by like
every news outlet and they didn't the
guys that reality kings didn't care that
had nothing to do with their product it
was just they just wanted them watermark
yeah really yeah they paid well for that
yeah they paid well man out of college I
mean it's a really it was a real it's
more than most of the people I know are
making now where did you get these two
old guys for the Katy Perry California
girls
ah Craigslist of course so what is that
how do you come how do you compose said
Craigslist Edie I think it was just I
think I probably still have it actually
saved somewhere we've posted some weird
craigslist address don't get me wrong
but it was like you don't really own
your senior citizen to star in music
video parody and it was just like for me
to basically be nude and dressed like a
yeah when did you tell him that when
zember the audition we're like this is
like I'm like we're like are you
comfortable wearing a bikini and this
one guy was like ah Alan is his name the
guy who ended up using in a lot of
videos Alan he was just like yeah we're
whatever longer you know fine like it
sounds like fun to me they all just
wanted to like they're just bored and
they wanted to do something fun
yeah he played Justin Bieber right after
he was good as Bieber in the diaper that
was one of my favorites
honestly the Bieber one God that one
gets me gone some of that my old videos
make me laugh harder than my new ones so
what well you know an interesting thing
is is I can I can relate to that I think
that when we'll get into this of what
you're doing now which is a fine-tuned
thing that is really it is working and
you can kind of we I think we know why
it works you know why it works and why
you continue to do it but when you see
something like those two dudes doing the
Katy Perry song you see there's an extra
amount of hate on that video and just
dislikes because because it's just a
weird sense of humor right but it's just
it's so weird it's funny right right but
it's not the kind of thing that has this
it's not gonna have the mass appeal
appeal it's Tim and Eric
yes tile right and that's honestly where
I got my inspiration for that video like
my old videos were all green-screen
tacky backgrounds wanted to make it look
cartoony and at the time I was also
thinking though like how do I do
something that'll make me different than
you know every other kid trying to put
up a music video or something like that
cuz there's so many and and I was like
well it was just do something totally
weird that'll get picked up by news
outlets because that was the only way to
get views at first when you don't have
subscribers you got to rely on websites
and bloggers to pick you up so how many
of these these water marked videos did
you do oh good question how long did you
say am I think there's like is there
maybe six of them or something as you
started with tik-tok and it ended with
only girl in the world so did you end up
also editing porn for them not know you
know what we did do though we made some
theme songs for them which is really
cool like I made the milf hunter theme
song what song the milf hunter milf
undersea or just a vide that's one of
our websites the hunter it's like a
drunk guy who has sex with mothers and
honey and you wrote his theme so I wrote
it because they just they just had
signed a deal with a Direct TV to have
their channel on DirecTV so they needed
all these theme songs for their mute for
their shows can you hum a little bit of
it I mean it was like it was really 80s
I think it was like you can find am on
the hunt no no no no no no looking for
my mom no no no no no no that's all I
don't remember the rest but it was your
vocals yeah my vocals did you also play
it was there like the milf part and you
like Roger
voice up no I do that no it was just
straight up just like a hit theme song
yeah we had some interesting roles we
play it was me up buddy now we weren't
in them we just did the music me and my
friend moved there together
okay um because we were both in the boom
boom pow parody and I was like oh I work
with my friend so can we both come and
they're like sure so we both moved to
Miami together which was sweet cuz I had
someone it was kind of like the dynamic
you guys have we work together on every
video and then you're you you know do
you tell your parents I'm you know I'm
working for they knew what was up they
knew exactly what was happening
the Grandma and Grandpa didn't I don't
think they did I told them their their
their secret name is world net media so
that's kind of like the okay the actual
company if you go and interview for it
or look it up its world that media they
had a lot of other websites dating and
stuff like that and what I mean so they
your parents knew about it but what did
they say they I mean they were they were
kind of freaked out it's like their son
straight out of college is working for
this company they didn't know what
exactly what I was doing day to day and
neither did the company really because a
lot of times we wouldn't show up like we
would we'd go to work at like 2:00 and
nobody would there we didn't really have
a boss it was weird they kind of hired
us as this new truck they were trying to
help this new like like branch a
watermark yeah it's like let's say they
gave you a watermark and then you just
did whatever you want and it was
originally supposed to be the YouTube
channel it's supposed to be like reality
King slash reality kings but they let
you do it all on your own channel yeah
fine they did it was just lucky that
that happened because so what happened
was we put up a video and it got it got
18 plus I think and I said well the
reason that's happening is because I'm
you're not partners I'm a partner so I
get preferential treatment will also get
better listings and the searches and
will get you know whatever the hell it's
called featured so you had already
gotten partnered based on the other
stuff some of those early period yeah
which raises another question
because I've heard multiple things from
multiple people you know sometimes you
hear people say well if you if you get
into this parity thing you're gonna have
to change the tune of the song just
enough in order for you to be able to
not have it pulled and I mean so wait
what's the actual deal on that I didn't
monetize any of my videos until I
started making them actual parodies
because my original videos were satires
if you think about it a satire makes fun
of a different topic but takes the
original instrumental and that's weird
oh that's what most exactly that's why
we're Dallas to get permission legally a
parody has to comment on or criticize
the original and an ironic or humorous
way so we do all those things by making
fun of the artist making fun of the
video recreating the video shot for shot
making fun of the song so we cover all
those bases if you do that legally you
know it's fair use right but you have to
cook you have to do it that way
and we've never had any legal issues
really to this day a lot of people have
legal issues shane has been having legal
issues right that's crazy
well the Lord video what happened with
that what was the what was the scenario
would that would being taken down yeah
so that one was taken down and you know
it was a it was a full-on takedown add
to I to do copyright school I don't know
if you guys have ever had to do that
it's like a snow but you you so traffic
traffic so like just prove that you went
through it I mean yeah he gave us a good
synopsis of fair use right then Oh
parody versus satire I know I know it
like the back of my hand so what was the
original video why was it taken down and
then the Lord won yeah it was they they
took it down for they said you know it
was the musical composition that was
what it was filed under okay and then
the next day well I made a video when I
found out right away and I put it up
when I'm like you know this is if you
guys agree tweet at the publisher and I
guess they did obviously they did it I
saw they did it was crazy
it was like every five seconds like the
publisher was probably like freaking out
and then it was back the next day and
the publisher apologized on Twitter and
they're like that was not us that was
our that was an automatic machine like
but that's not true because you can't
in order to file a takedown you have to
do it by hand and manually right so they
basically just kind of realize that I
have a feeling they were going through
all the parodies which probably most
weren't legal and done correctly and
just taking them down or trying to claim
them mm-hmm
and then when they took this one down
I'm sure they're lawyers looked at in
there like you duh you better put it
back you better put it back up right now
so but you still because of the process
you had to do the copyright school thing
oh yeah I had to do the copyright school
you can't even access your channel again
till you do it and so is that like an
online it's just a real thing online
yeah I got every answer right I didn't
even watch the video so they make you
watch like an hour-long video I'm like
that I knew all the and is that for one
strike once yeah once right so you got
to keep taking it if you get another
woman it's kind of ridiculous but hmm
but you you were already employing the
strategy of creating things as a
technical parody not yeah yeah not as a
what's the other word satire yeah I was
yeah so but there's my dad trying to
FaceTime me haha just put it on speaker
we can talk to him the officer we talk
to him yeah just tell him it's he's on
our podcast and we're just um we're
basically live let me try to get him let
me try to connect with him he's trying
to do FaceTime audio dad hello buddy hey
Dad I'm on a I'm sure I'm doing a
podcast right now with rhett and Link so
you're on with them we're just talking
about how you're such a big fan of all
the youtubers mister Baker can we call
you buddy okay it's like yeah you call
me buddy okay it's kind of hard to
explain but up into this moment when I
thought about buddy
I thought about a blind man's dog am I
blind uncle but now I'm gonna think
about you from now on okay
think about dogs yeah that's not the
first time you've heard that I'm sure no
no my my uncle Melvin was blind but his
dog buddy could see really well and
smell really well he's a beagle yeah
that are you fangirling right now yeah
I'm in north of the El Yunque National
Forest you get you get Internet there
obviously well I'm actually back in my
hotel room right now
well you thank God right over in the
National Forest right now I was over
there hiking around mom told me not to
but I was hiking around in the National
by yourself yeah it's dangerous and you
don't even you can't even watch YouTube
they're getting you Wow well you know
what buddy we were why don't you give a
plug to your Instagram so we know
everyone everyone it wants to follow you
on that what's your Instagram handle w
baker III right he's the third we're all
actually named Walter really links a
third really yeah my son is a four oh
wow so what's your middle name we say
strange but Bart says well but I'm the
fourth one with no little name it's not
that straight yeah it's not that strange
really it's not well why don't I call
you back after I finish up all right all
right love you too man bye well he is
buddy hey I'm gonna see those pictures
of Puerto Rico
yeah he's definitely gonna take a bunch
of selfies there I wish he would have
called earlier this would have been a
good
well sorry guys just kidding so um we're
doing we're doing a potential reality TV
show based on these parodies so it's
like the making it's like making them
video right but it's like with the
parodies and then half of it'll be like
all the that goes on we're producing and
coming up with the ideas and the other
half will just be whatever a personal
life which is probably going to be all
set up right fit reality TV yeah of
course um so and how how far along is
that is it just a concept no that's far
enough along where they've are that's
we're doing it right now with bandage a
who is bounnam and Murray like you know
real world the Kardashians are like okay
they contacted me like I'm maybe a month
I go to three weeks ago they moved so
quickly they already interviewed all my
staff they've been shoots they've cut a
sizzler and really they've presented it
to their CEO and co o said do it and
they're trying to sell it to E which
would be dope okay and then what what
what's the working title we don't know
yet we don't know yet it's called the
Bart Baker project right now okay you
might be that might be the name it might
be better than who knows it's not bad
name really um but they you know where
does the drama come from that actually
exists besides in the comments like
what's the real-life drama it's it's a
lot of uh just
well the shoot days he'll always cram
and everything in like 12 hours I mean
my producers are having heart attacks
because isn't there there's like a kind
of a race you don't you want to their
timing is means so much for this another
thing right so what's the so walk me
through from okay Taylor Swift reliefs
releases blank space you're watching the
video you're reading to come to hate her
comments on her video you're being
inspired
I mean how quickly do you want to turn
around a parody and you know you're
writing the lyrics you got people who
also write kind of pitch things at this
point yeah but how quickly do you need
to get yours up um is it kind of a loser
it's kind of loose so sometimes it's
good to get it up quick sometimes it's
good to wait so it has more exposed
in the long run like we just did uptown
funk but it's been out for three months
something like that okay so that's
that's a long psych it starts slow some
of them blow up right away that one blew
up gradually so we put it on the back
burner Taylor Swift we knew right away
we had to do it as soon as possible it
still took three weeks because getting a
house like that's hell but you've got
someone who's creating like a sound of
like track
you're not just ripping the karaoke
track now we got someone recreating
everything will scratch and they have to
change a little bit right it's not
changed tune wise no right so it's
basically you don't have to change we
don't have to change because they're you
so you can take a certain amount of
something and and use it and and then
when you're writing the song kind of
stepping through the process you kind of
talked about this line of you know the
more harsh you are the the more response
you're gonna get positive and negative
any classes good press sure but you you
seem to say that there is a there's a
line that you don't want to cross yeah
you have to pull back um yeah what it
kind of helped to clarify what that line
is for you it's whatever I would
personally feel uncomfortable like
conveying to everybody I like to
everybody or the artists face like
you're singing to Katy Perry or Nicki
Minaj saying I can yeah I'm comfortable
saying and Nicki I don't you're away
you're wasting your talent yeah that's
literally a lyric right or is your
evaluation I'm comfortable saying that
to the odd I don't think I would know
it's if I'm comfortable I'd never think
about saying it to the artist because
then I would never say something
directly to an artist like that because
I don't actually a lot of the stuff I
don't actually mean it's just stuff that
it's I know people will will agree with
and I know we'll get views
mm-hm and I know we'll be funny but like
a lot of that like I always say most of
the artists that I make fun of and roast
it's a roast basically right but it's
not it so it's not an editorial piece
this is not Bart Baker's feelings about
this artist now this is your paint
you're playing a character almost you're
embodying the
hater yeah that already exists online
right so it's almost like that and it's
also just picking apart the video and
everything like that and but a lot of
the times I like the videos I like the
song I mean I bump it I'm bumping Bieber
in my car you know I don't I don't have
anything against these people I'd love
to meet all these people in work with
these people
uh and I hope most people can understand
that it's just a comedy and it's like
it's like well you know it's just it's
the kits like when you roast someone you
say them mean it but yeah but you kind
of do it in a way that's paying homage
to alright so it's like oh I'm saying
all this mean it's not supposed to be
taken seriously it's supposed to make
people laugh
so that's honestly that's that's that's
how I feel do you think that's how the
artist takes it and what have you who
has responded pitbull
saw the pip wanted about him which was
pretty harsh what's the harshest line in
that one oh my god what was it I mean
the whole the whole concept was that
he's a that he's a sellout for all those
sponsors the harshest line itself was
well at the very end their heads explode
and it's like this guy is like huh thank
god those douche bags are dead and then
all the World Cup sales goes through the
roof because that was their song as a
World Cup song huh yeah it was just
really stuff that people always see
budding people I hate you so much I wish
you were dead that's that yeah that's
that's pretty far right pretty bad so
then he turns around and what his
pitbulls say he loved it he thought it
was funny and he he was like respect was
this on Twitter or a phone call this was
a video call you through your dad yeah
until Bush was in this was on Twitter he
tweeted the video and he said thanks for
the love Thanks thanks for the laughs
yeah uh I haven't watched this yet yeah
I'm too busy to watch this and then he
were invited me to be in his music video
so did you do that yeah I was in it and
I met him which one fireball yeah
fireball yeah one of the lines in the
video was
pull my pants up to the sky wait too
high because he's always got like a
pitbulls going on you know I mean uh-huh
and he's like he's like a pop oh I don't
pull my pencil that I now do I that's
the first thing he said to me hahaha and
then we took pictures but he was and
then he was sooo he's soaked he's super
cool and he's after we shot with he was
like he was like we need to do stuff
together I'll help you write stuff and
come up with concepts for if you're
doing a parody just let me know and I'll
I want to be involved he's just like I
understand didn't really mean that he
seemed like you did he had some vodka
though so he did he pick up on the my a
meanness of you I don't know if he knows
that I went to Miami I don't know if I
told him that but it would like when I
look at the end of your videos it's like
when you're doing your vlog like the way
you know your tank top and the way you
wear your hat I think that Bart is Miami
yeah yeah I mean yeah I mean I don't
know maybe something about the Hat in
that way yeah like your hats got a lot
of sequins on it oh that I that's what I
think of Miami Miami is very sequiny
yeah it was like ed hardy and everyone
add that there but you don't
so do you don't consider yourself like
repping Miami I don't think so in
apparel standpoint no I feel like it's
more LA at this point yeah definitely
not Chicago though yeah now a guy like
pitbull to me I my speculation is he's
just a smart guy that knows that the
best way to handle what you have done is
to embrace it yeah but you know as well
as anybody who does stuff that people
can criticize sure that when people say
things that could be true you know the
things the doubts that you might have
about yourself it hurts people you know
it Taylor Swift watches this and I think
if somebody like Taylor Swift watching
this thing and just getting mad yeah you
know I can see that and it's almost kind
of what you're pointing out in the way
that you portray her I mean I can't
imagine her laughing it off pitbull yeah
yeah it's like bring this guy over you
know you can kind of tell or
like you would have the kind idea of how
they would react to it so when you think
about that when you when you have this
mental picture of Taylor Swift sitting
there just getting pissed yeah that you
or hurt
I picture her organize what it has a
mini feel I just it's so it's so hard I
mean I can understand them maybe her
feeling like like kind of hurt by it but
at the same time it's like I'm not
targeting her directly and and we do
every artist so it's like just if they
can just see you you want you are
targeting her directly but yeah right
right it's like every artist is in we're
just hitting everyone and it's not like
it we I think people would should know
by now that we don't have anything
against them as an artist because we do
every single artist it's just that's
what that's what we do and you have to
find an angle yeah you have to find an
angle that angle is you know she's a
devil people like it yeah there are but
there are other choices that are risky
for different reasons and then the risk
isn't that you might hurt their feelings
hmm but get it taken down or you know if
somebody like Kanye is so volatile well
are you are you sure that you want to
dawn black face Oh God and play him with
your Chiefs cheeks puffed out like that
I mean what was behind you know what was
what was behind that that led to that
decision I mean was there a risk
calculation in there imma let you finish
but first you want to send someone after
you yeah um no I didn't even think about
it because I cannot Suge Knight and I
don't think you should do that with Suge
Knight no um and then walk around in a
parking lot in front of his truck or
anything yeah that was just like uh it
was just it all came down to the fact
that I just didn't want anyone else
playing the character at that point and
now I just wanted to play the character
I never thought about it as black face I
just was like put me in makeup make me
look as much like him as you can and no
one in your squad said you know what
this is blackface you do know that this
is like people are gonna
like it was bad they said like it could
be bad but nobody said don't do it I
mean first of all I'll be honest with
you I was surprised that there were only
you know there's only like 5,000
dislikes on that video yeah and and I
and so I was expecting it to be you know
just like you know tens of thousands of
dislikes and yeah and there's lots of
comments
hey this is racist and there's less
people who are like well he's playing a
character yeah yeah I mean don't you do
it again I guess is the question though
I don't I there I think that there's a I
don't want to play Kanye again and I
don't think I need to I feel like at
this point I'll get someone else to play
those characters like there's certain
characters I will play and it's like
Drake or cuz Drake is his lighter
skinned people just have this thing in
their mind that it's racist to do any
likes coloration of your skin like
that's just something that's always
gonna be there and blackface itself is
so different the whole thing was just
like blatantly being you paint your face
black and then you're just being racist
making right of every single
characteristic and when we when I did
that I was like we're not gonna mention
anything about the fact that he's black
everyone knows that it's just like if
I'm gonna play him I can't have white
skin darkened me up put on a bald cap
but then you get your parody of the Lord
you know you write and sing that she her
lyrics are racist so that's kind of is
that kind of hypocritical there that
you're making fun of her for saying now
I'm gonna list out everything that I
think black people like Chris style oh
how do you say it right crystal Chris
yeah well those are almost a joke what I
did there but it was not intentional
people can interpret being I mean I was
saying that because it was a news
article I found like unlike a website
like oh Lord
wrote this song about hip-hop culture so
again so you were in bodying someone
else
this criticism you kind of channeled
that in the parody I think that's
interesting
I'd yeah it's it's certainly not a way
that it's not a first way that you view
your videos I think that um it's an
interesting I don't know I don't know if
I'd call it a defense may just an
explanation I certainly think you're
just being honest I find it
you know I'm wonder if people are
thinking right now well that's a
rationalization I mean it but whenever
you say it whenever you sing it it
becomes it becomes your point of view or
doesn't it have to I mean you're saying
no yeah I mean it's why it's my point of
view during that video I guess something
I don't agree with a lot of the stuff
that we're just blowing at I proportion
purposely have you ever felt the need to
somehow offer that explanation like you
know okay well everyone do your fans
know that that's what you're doing that
you're kind of embodying my hater fans
know my hardcore fans know all the
comments where people are really angry
or people who stumble upon the video and
don't have a clue that there's a whole
slew of these for every single person
out there who's you know but they just
find this one and they're like wow this
person must really hate whatever Lord to
make it radio it's like they did this
video just like about Lord saying all
this mean stuff like they must and does
that I mean do you get tired of that
yeah the comments yeah yeah but you've
never said that I'm I don't believe all
these things I'm just embodying the
haters so I've never said it's like a
double level priority I said that on a
my last video I left a comment on it
saying that because that was all the
original video is all about how the all
the controversy was because she was 12
and he was 28 dancing together right so
I said and I blew that a proportion they
get arrested at the end because you know
anyway and then I left a comment on that
I'm like I don't actually think that
that was what all the comments were on
the original video
so we took that and of course we're
gonna make fun of that because that's
what the news is
right that's people's yes the perception
that's the perception that's what people
are getting all up in arms about on the
original that's what we're gonna make
fun of now and it's an interesting thing
because it works so well and it's kind
of the key to your success right now you
know not that you aren't capable of
other things but you had this this angle
that is really working yeah so does that
create a do you ever think okay well now
my job is I see the latest music video
that comes out and now I've got to
figure out how to embody embody the
negative perspective on this video to
make my video kind of yeah you have to
put a spin on it like uptown funk was
really hard that song in the video or
awesome like you you see it you're like
okay here it is everybody likes this a
lot I've got to hate this for everybody
yeah and that yeah I think it's also
like and and so tell us what what where
you landed and how you got with uptown
funk yeah so uptown funk was like it's
very hard to find something sometimes
it's like we let's do it in a way that's
poking fun of what's happening in the
video as opposed to totally going after
the artists cuz sometimes you don't have
anything to go after cuz what can you
say about Bruno Mars writing just the
cocaine thing that's it right you got
arrested for cocaine and the whole song
is like an 80s vibe whatever funk music
so we're like I'll be funny let's just
at least incorporate the fact that's why
they're all dancing around the streets
with a group of dudes and give them some
cocaine you know that would be funny at
least we can hit him with one thing
there and then then like what's going on
in the video they're there walking
around look trying to pick up women the
women are not interested at all stuff
like that the fact that you know they're
there why are they driving around the
car and they're all dancing but Mark
Ronson's never allowed to dance so we
made this whole thing up like okay mark
ronson is never allowed to dance because
he just can't dance and he's trying to
fit in but he can't fit in so throughout
the whole video that was like a concept
we made fun of that so there one the
Michael Jackson and then Michael Jackson
because there was just a news fake news
thing that had gone out saying Michael
Jackson
it's like it's his son so we're like
like okay and it went viral one day on
Facebook you know how these things are
and it was probably trending on Twitter
and so we're like that's funny
like I could actually see some people
believing that obviously people people
did believe it for a day
so if okay so you're the you're the
master embodiment of haters are your you
know hater comment videos what do you
call it but her kaaba's butthurt
comments is that just another give me
give me the pitch of what those are
those what the actual show is what the
comments are the show the show is me
reading the top five basically angriest
comments about me directed directly at
me usually it's like really brutal okay
yeah so but it's funny because it just
gets more and more illiterate angrier
angrier there yeah I mean what made you
think I need to do this reading the
comments maybe that was making me laugh
really hard because it was like I can
just picture these people sitting in
their bedrooms pounding on their
computer so angry over something that's
meant to make people laugh you know and
they take it so seriously so I was like
let's I think it'd be funny to make a
serious just reading them and how people
responded to it people people love that
series the problem is I feel like a lot
of the comments now on my videos are all
negative because they all want to be on
the harder be featured to be featured so
so many comments are fake now it's hard
to tell who's really mad just people
going completely over-the-top it's just
all angry which is great for the
comments section because then it's more
people fighting but yeah you know yeah I
don't I can't even read the comments
anymore dude I can't because I had so
much notes not has there ever been a
comment before it was hard to tell if
they were sincere yeah that hit home for
years oh this this hit me where it hurts
that ever happened to you the tables
being turned
it's not so much comments directly
attacking me that I care about because
that's whatever you know people can say
whatever they want about me and I
understand that and it's fine
I think it's stuff where people are like
you're being a bully or something like
that like you're gonna hurt their
feelings where I feel like am I being
too mean and I didn't know people would
actually think I was bad there's like
saying this from the bottom of my heart
like I mean all this stuff and some
people think that and that's when people
actually think that you know let and I'm
sure they're very young and they're just
like that's what your initial reaction
is this is someone who really feels this
way because they made a video um that
makes me feel sometimes just like bad
like because that's not my intention to
be misunderstood yeah I don't want but
I'd that's like it like I said it's like
if I met these artists in person like
when I met pitbull or someone like that
like I would be the first thing I would
say is like I'm a huge fan of you guys
like I didn't just wasn't meant to be
taken seriously I hope you would know
that and when people don't know that it
makes me feel like I I hope that the
artists don't feel that way mm-hmm if
you had to if you had to parody yourself
I'm going to so I'm gonna start I'm
doing original music okay here we're
gonna start doing original music why the
hell not I've studied pop music I know
it you know I'm gonna do a music video
and I'm gonna parody my own music video
figure why the okay so the first one is
it gonna be a comedy song or a snow
there's gonna be serious like but
serious fun right like like Ke$ha that's
pop hip-hop okay it's serious but it's
fun light-hearted light-hearted I don't
it's not jokes it's not it's no it's not
jokes hearty music the video could be
funny right so it's something that could
play on the radio that's catchy that's
not like oh this is comedy but the video
itself would be comedy because with you
who would you want to play you if you
weren't gonna put pair to yourself
because that would be it yeah that would
be a total turn the tables
if you know well that would probably
happen right if I put out a music video
on my channel of myself doing an
original song I'm sure people are gonna
make a parody of it right they're like
we got it let's get him back no but you
said you were gonna produce the pair and
I'm gonna do it and play myself okay
can I make a suggestion that'd be
hilarious yes
Vanilla's oh my god dude vanilla ice
this is here play you second uh this is
yesterday Roman Atwood kept call me
Vanilla Ice all day
well there's the Miami thing yeah I mean
he's he's got he's got a lot of years on
you he just got arrested - for stealing
from my home it was it was a
misunderstanding I believe it I think
you okay I think it wasn't either but I
mean I'm not saying it should be him but
that would really do it is if you
allowed someone that would play you
because you know when you play yourself
there's only so much all he's making fun
of himself that is fun you didn't ask my
opinion right and I've given you three
right that's interesting well you can
parody multiple ones maybe you wanted
yourself maybe one is call it robber no
I mean Winkle on Ebro and probably do it
yeah you would that before I'm not gonna
say he would but I would I would hope
that he would there's a lot of stuff to
make fun of me for I'm excited so so
lastly I think that's brilliant
so what got my idea but just your idea
to do it I can't wait to see so what
would you do it on that before you know
you're gonna obviously you're you're
already thinking about this yeah like if
you had if you have to think about the
things that you would sort of zero in
about yourself to parity I think what
people what people perceive me as right
a douchebag that's like one of the main
comments I'll get I mean that's a lot of
people get that you know they make fun
of when I have my hair gone that's like
it's higher than yours so I got a stupid
little faux hawk and his big glasses
look just stupid earrings I'm gonna
loser stuff like that right it's like oh
what a poser he's trying to be like
Bieber he wears his hats backwards like
Bieber like you know stuff like that oh
you were supras his apparel his apparel
embodies miami what does that mean right
right so I mean look at thinking like
that we could go and read
we could find so many awesome things to
make fun of me for which is what people
are making fun of me for and that they
can relate to that because they're the
ones saying it what's the and we all
have insecurities but what you know
would you be willing to tell us what's
what's an actual insecurity an actual
insecurity like you know Bart Baker
going to sleep at night that the thought
in his head that if this thing was ever
a comment um I would hurt jeez that's
tough there's nothing you don't like
about yourself oh I mean yeah sure
people to know but you but you're gonna
be forced to say on a podcast
it doesn't have to be a secret it could
be also something that once people say
oh they're like yeah yeah but I think
it's not like I have a lot of
insecurities obviously just about it all
that stuff in general because that's the
comments that I read but I can't really
single anything in particular that if I
saw and a comment would be like would
hit me hard not in a comment I think
just my okay not in a comment securities
in general um just just people losing
interest in Who I am as a person right
like falling off the map
getting older mm-hmm I am wrapped by a
management company that has 14 year olds
so it's crazy to me that
how are you I'm 28 nobody knows how old
I am really except for freaking
Wikipedia that I mean that that's like
an insecurity just in the space yeah
right now it's so it's getting so young
because how old do you feel like you
need to be perceived as to be to remain
successful um what's that number I feel
like everyone I meet thinks I'm 21 to 25
so I don't know why that's like the
sweet spot but I think 25 if you can
stay 25 for a long time yeah you know
because then 30 scary
I mean that's coming up and then I don't
know it's like people are people gonna
change their perception of me and then
it's also strange because I'm meeting
all these fans and they're so young but
they're like oh my god we love you
you're so cute and stuff when it's just
like strange because they don't know how
old I am
they don't have any cut they don't have
any be your father Yeah right wasn't
making a joke he was he was being seen
to be your father kid I might be no but
I might be I'm joking I don't want to
derail this sincerity here because I
appreciate it you know I'm about to be
37 and I know a guy who already is you
know mean just to put the just to put
the shoe on the other foot yeah I've got
gray hair yeah I don't want anybody to
know that yeah you know like I have to
shave because there's gray hair down
here in the beer right like you can
probably see it now because it's been a
long day it's like I you know what if
somebody comments about that right and
it scares me that coming oh there's that
yeah I have that insecurity and so you
know I'll put that out there since I put
you on the spot that I'll for sure
that's a comma that if you think you're
old you've made us just feel that much
worse it's just it's so it says it's
just the space is so strangely
young right now right yeah and it's not
YouTube in general I feel like the most
successful people on YouTube were all
older right now still like they're
they're not 14 they're not even in their
teens a lot of them are 20s 30s but you
have to but you have to have this
conversation with yourself and so DeWitt
yeah so what if the thing is like in it
it's like harder like how long will I
keep getting Instagram followers who's
looking at my pictures when I am like
you know in ten years am I gonna take
post up selfie and have like 13
year-olds click like you know what I
mean but that's the audience that's so
engaged on those platforms they are I
mean I think that you you know we relate
to this already already being 10 years
ahead of you yeah I think that you know
one of the things that that we hope is
that you know the reason the reason
they're so young is
because this is so new yeah but they're
gonna stick around right right no yeah
for sure but I think that you know
you're you're kind of given an answer to
the insecurities but I think that it's
it's kind of just an interesting just to
say hey this is what it is and we can
rationalize and that's a true
rationalization yeah and maybe they
won't maybe they maybe they won't stick
around and maybe this is we've all
peeked maybe that's maybe that's the
reality maybe we've all peeked yeah and
then we just got to figure out how to
channel it and you know and make a
living yeah that could be a reality at
the same time it's like we're doing
content that's actually content driven
and as opposed to content that's and
driven by the fact that we're cute right
it's not like the girls are watching
these videos like oh he's so cute what a
fun little video they're like this video
is good and funny we're watching it and
it's actually viral right but so then it
goes to the other end security that you
seem to say what if people actually
think I'm a douche bag yeah yeah that
another one
I think insecurities awake at night so
to speak that's just an insecurity I
have in general always when I don't when
I when I'm when I first meet people it's
very hard for me to tell what they think
because they all have a perception of me
as this guy at the end of its videos
right like yo guys what's up thanks for
watching my parody blah blah blah and
that's just me on camera getting people
to watch more parodies that's how I am
in front of the camera I'm different
when I'm off the camera and people don't
know that until they meet me so I always
kind of have this thing in the back of
my mind like do they what do they think
right now do they think I'm this
freaking like wannabe white rapper guy
who's like in your face 24/7 this is
like a d-bag who's just trying to make
money on YouTube like so that's it's hot
first impression stuff like that it's
hard for me to tell how people actually
feel yeah I mean that's just how it is
in general and the so you're describing
somewhere between a character bar Baker
yeah or just a
and amped up this is not a normal
interpersonal volume right that I a dot
yeah I think and then that's like the
first thing everyone says to is like
well you're super mellow compared to
your videos but like when you met me or
I know you met Rhett last time yeah
was that it is does it does it go
through your mind like when you meet
people like us is that what's happening
wow they you know I wonder if they'll
get to know the actual Bart I think it
goes through my mind whenever I meet
somebody in the space when we first meet
it's like it's very hard to tell what
people's intentions are when you're
meeting them and we're all cuz it's like
some people are so some people are so
selfish and they're all been they're
bitter that you're successful like you
know even if they're successful and it's
like you're like what's up dude you
they're like nice to meet you and you
can't tell if they really think it's
nice to meet you if they're just saying
that you know because it's like let's
make friends with all the other people
who are doing well so we can all do well
together and it's all fake it's hard to
tell what's real it's just that it's
hard and this may not be friends but
let's collab yeah let's let's collab and
then let's never talk yeah you know
stuff like that
and then I don't know there's it's just
uh it's it's unfortunate but everyone
kind of is like I feel like has a little
chip on their shoulder like is this
person being truthful or is this person
trying to get my email address and be
like let's shoot a video let's well
there is that dynamic that when someone
is succeeding you're you're like I want
to be happy for them I want to know how
they're doing it sure and I wish I could
that was me
yeah and and we all and if we've been in
this for a long time like you have yeah
there's been so many ebbs and flows that
you see oh well this is working for them
now this is not working for us anymore
though this is really working for us
right now and yeah it's uh it's like a
sort of weird high school debate team
competition that never goes away well
the whole the whole thing especially
VidCon playlist I feel like it's a it's
like a popularity competition still
right it's like oh well
how many Instagram father do you have
it's it's interesting I mean you're
describing kind of the interpersonal
interactions between creators and
youtubers but I think that anyone can
relate to I think it's a good lesson for
anyone to learn that uh we well you know
it's as humans for some reason we just
want to make a snap judgment about
somebody and just put them in a box slap
a label on them you know and you have to
fight that you know I feel like this
conversation
is a reminder for me and getting to know
you that you know okay
my tendency maybe it's a human tendency
maybe it's just a link problem is to
want to put somebody in a box and slap a
label on the box and say okay I have a
formed opinion about this person because
I watched the first half of eight videos
yeah you know and then I skipped to the
end block once and now I can make a
vanilla ice joke you know yes I mean
who's who's that who's the bad guy here
the person that I put in the box or me
you know and I think I hope that it's a
human tendency and it's not just my
problem no they want to want to label
people right and so I think this is a
good reminder that yeah you know okay
and I'll just give an example I think I
didn't anticipate your answer your
rationale behind embodying the haters
instead of just saying oh that I'm just
doing this for the views or I really
believe this you know I just found
myself thinking well there's a couple
options here and I'm just gonna I'm
gonna choose the most likely one and
then I'm gonna come at it from that
angle right and it wasn't it wasn't your
answer so it kind of surprised me a
little bit said okay maybe everything
you assume is not correct about somebody
yeah about you in this case or yeah
people in general I think that's a
that's a good lesson
it is so thanks Bart oh no problem glad
I could help
well we'll be following your dad on
Instagram yeah you need to and my mom
has one too oh really go ahead and throw
that up I think it's just Bart's mom
Bart Baker's mom oh really she's yeah
she's chief and moms do
600 likes a picture she's Bart's mom
really yeah mom Janek I'm trying to get
some brand deals man she's good like 10%
next time they're here we'll we'll see
if we can give them your biscuit but for
now it's time for you to sign the table
hot dope dim lighting let's do it thanks
man it's fine
yeah yeah that was funny it got really
interesting actually
oh it did yeah I mean I didn't you can
share something you learned too if this
is like show-and-tell I what did I learn
I just what did you learn today Bart I
learned that that talking about my
feelings surrounding YouTube and my
insecurities is good it makes you feel
better in the long run and there you
have it our Bart bass work Bart bass gir
Bart Baker be a skit it's what I thought
I was gonna get some great alliteration
and a good a said Bart bass get Barlow
at the Bart Baker biscuit is the Bart
bass kid let Bart know and us know at
the same time what you think of our
conversation with him on Twitter tweet
at him Bart Baker and use hashtag ear
biscuits we truly appreciate when you
guys tweet at our guest and include us
we read those I know they do I feel like
I've learned I learned some stuff I'm
curious if you did I did you are my
people have you people yeah yeah people
here in the room with me one of the
fascinating things that I found I always
love to learn about the process that
someone applies to something like this
and I think I along with most everyone
else brings a certain set of assumptions
to the process and when I watch a Bart
Baker music video a lot of times I'm
like oh man he's going there he's saying
that thing about this artist because he
believed harsh it's an artistic it's a
artistic representation of his personal
opinion that would be the perception
right right but what I learned in
talking with Bart is that he is
essentially taking what the Internet is
already saying
about this person and their video and
he's distilling it
channeling the collective criticism yet
the internet is fascinating and it does
two things number one user beam of
criticism but it there's two things and
number one thing is is when you do that
you're tapping into what people want to
be said about something and that it
helps to explain the crazy popularity I
mean there's lots of things that explain
the crazy popularity of these videos you
know the fact that the production design
is amazing the fact that he looks as
much as you can look like a person who
is not you the fact that the musical
production is exactly a recreation of it
but you add in the fact that he's saying
the things that the Internet's already
saying but he's saying them in a funny
way that fits into the context of the
song yeah I mean it's just a recipe for
a lot of hits all new YouTube but it
makes me think of the the principle of
persuasion that you can either tell
somebody to do something or you can help
you can get someone to do something by
getting them to think they came up with
it and this reminds me of that in a
little way that you know you think that
I have tremendous insight and I'm not
saying he doesn't but his insight is
channeling their criticism and making it
seem like giving them something to
resonate it's like hearing it and giving
it back to them that's a not a principle
of persuasion it is and I don't want to
belittle the fact that borrow Bart and
the guys that he works with genius
they're they're writing I mean they're
not just taking ideas from comments but
the fact that they are heavily informed
by the general tide in the general
public perception of a person a lot of
alliteration in that sentence I think
that's even more genius in one sense
leave us a review on iTunes and comment
along with the conversation on
soundcloud those things help us out as
well and you know we'll continue to help
you out if as long as you consider this
help I don't know if this is a help or
just entertainment for you
I mean you know make it three but it's
like hey listen is your drive as long as
we can find the bread dough we will keep
coming back and making biscuits and that
was an analogy about what keep getting
paid it was just literally he means
literally we have we have we have dough
here and you would
believe it it's we're surrounded in it
right surround it by it
[Music]
[Music]